testing testing
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to our planning committee
meeting today before we begin i would
like to ask our new principal clerk
sarah sternberg to explain the health
and safety arrangements for our meeting
[Music]
thank you chair good afternoon members
simply to say that we will follow the
approach taken at yesterday's council
meeting
um
the room is ventilated sanitizers are
available and as you can see the
perspective signs
screens are in place thank you chair
thank you
bye someone on today's agenda is the
apologies for absence happy ending uh
yes sir we have apologies from
councillor hancock who's been
substituted by council winley
uh councillor liggers who's been
substituted by councillor dayton and
we've also received apologies from
councillor ridgeway thank you chair
thank you no other apologies
non-received job okay
moving on to item two declarations of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
procunary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
or interests
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
non-received chat
thank you
moving on to item three minutes of the
last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 22nd of march 2022
are we happy that they are a correct
record and if so is there a mover more
rich
thank you
that's mark foster and alan powell thank
you
all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
and just one abstention
will be she wasn't here
promotion has been carried
now to the main item
of business
we have two applications the late
reputation representations reports and
the report on appeals lodged and
determined
i am happy with this and intend to
consider the order of business
before we begin
i would like the clerk to explain for
the benefit of members speakers and
those watching the meeting on youtube
how we deal with the applications
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
applications this afternoon
we will consider the two applications in
the order that they are set out on the
agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplements has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers to address the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask them
questions
if necessary to clarify any points which
they have made
when we have heard from the speakers
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and ultimately for determination by a
vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
once the application which a speaker has
come to speak on has been dealt with
then they may leave the chamber
if they choose to remain then they will
not be allowed to posit participate
further from that point
now as you're aware this meeting is
being live streamed and recording will
be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you we'll now turn to the main
business at hand and our first
application item 4 is ned 4
21
zero zero seven zero seven four slash fl
for wingerworth this application is for
a proposed new clubhouse and associated
parking
involved in involving amended plans at
winger worth junior sports association
thank you
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans of the site i will
allow the officers to complete the
presentation consequently members could
you please reserve any points of order
or questions
about the process till the end
thank you
over to you emily
thank you chad
and firstly maya confirmed that no late
representations have been received on
this item
members of planning committee attended
did a virtual site visit yesterday we
saw a range of photos taken from in and
around the application site i don't
intend to repeat the site visit photos
in this presentation
the material is
choose members
will need to assess and base your
decision on are as follows the principle
of the proposed development and whether
a new clubhouse is acceptable in the
location proposed went out
when assessed against the relevant
policies of the development plan the
impact of the development with regard to
design the impact of the proposed
clubhouse on the amenity of
neighbors and any impact on highway
safety officers are not aware of any
technical reasons why the application
cannot be determined today and i will
now run through the following slides
thank you the first slide illustrates
the site highlighted in orange the
application site is located east of
derby road and is accessed by silver
birch way part of the key living housing
development to the south home beam drive
thank you
here we have a block plan of the
proposed
site the site will be accessed by the
existing access point to the east which
leads to 12-car parking spaces and 12
cycle spaces the proposed clubhouse will
be positioned between
the five side
pitch to the east and the full size
football pitch to the south thank you
this is a 3d view of the proposed
clubhouse we've associated parking
to the front this will be the key public
view of the site
that ends the presentation thank you
chair
thank you
we have one speaker for this application
i'd like our speaker mr stops to take
the table uh he's the applicant to
address the committee
you'd like to confirm your name and you
have three minutes when you're ready
thank you chair um i am andy stops i am
the treasurer of wingworth jsa i don't
have a lot to say today hopefully that
you've seen a lot from the presentation
um just to give you some background so
the football club the football club was
founded 36 years ago
when a
boy came home from school and asked his
dad to
sort out a football team because there
was no pe
because of a teacher strike
the club has now got 260 children
playing in 22 teams
it's growing uh significantly and part
of that growth
is because of the development of houses
around that site
that's a positive of what's happening
the negative of that is the fact that
when this site was first put in place uh
there was a coking plant next to it it
was one of the most contaminated lands
in the country it's now ripe for
development and we feel a little bit
under attack
the provisions on that site are
literally some old porter cabin
buildings that have been there for a
long long time um we want to try and
make something significant and
substantial to provide sanctuary more
for the children for their parents and
spectators because it's it's not really
in keeping with a club of 260 children
um
there's been some uh
concerns raised about increased capacity
we don't see this clubhouse as being
something we want to rent out we see it
as being some somewhere whether we can
provide that sanctuary to those those
people
and the capacity of that is governed by
how many kids can play p can play
football and that's governed by how many
pitches there are we can't increase the
amount of space on that land so
therefore we don't see an increase of
capacity
with regards to that
um
we've overcome some objections with
regards to orchestral water and the pipe
has been laid under our ground
um with the highways we've provided
transport statements
um
we've also uh had cons consult
some consultation sorry with them sport
england uh because they're not that keen
on us taking away playing space so the
the the designs that you've seen don't
take away any space from what's
currently there
um and
i think that's most of the objections
that i've covered so that i'm just here
today to sort of you know answer any
questions that you may have as a
representative of the football club
um
so i appreciate you might want to ask
questions at a later stage thank you
thank you if you'd like to remain where
you are
are there any questions for mr stops
councillor hall
yeah yeah just one just to clarify
because where it says new clubhouse i
think you've virtually covered it anyway
you say currently there's some porter
cabins in place so just to clarify
because i can't see it in the paperwork
the clubhouse will replace the portal
cabins totally the
the intention actually is to
use some of the existing buildings on
site as part of the clubhouse and and
what sport england have said is they
don't want us to reduce any any playing
space so we any any port cabins or
buildings that are moved will be
reinstated as as a training pitch
actually so the clubhouse is on a place
which is currently like a dead playing
area as such um just so we don't lose
any any
additional plane space
okay councillor elliott
[Music]
it's just a quick one from me really i
mean obviously with the new estate going
up you're attracting all the the
children that are coming onto there and
i think that's admirable uh is it a
community asset or is it a private
concern the football the football club
yeah the club that's going to be built
it's it well it's
we're a not-for-profit sports
association
i don't know in terms of how our
constitution how that sits but when we
build it we'd like to in the in the
times frame that it can be open allow as
many people to use that site as possible
yeah does that answer your question yeah
yeah is it is it solely for football or
will there be you know like a room there
for pilates and what have you
that was the original plan yes okay
that's fine thank you
councillor foster
thank you chair uh thanks mr stops for
explaining that um
there's been a few concerns raised about
uh parking issues and parking controls
can you elaborate any further on that
now they've been addressed please yes so
before the housing developments were put
in place
there was no car parking issues there
was a road that went down to the coking
plant and for 30 odd years cars parked
along there
um
obviously there's now two housing
developments very close to where where
where our site is um the nearest being
the what was the the care homes
development the avenue plan
site we have the um
ability to use the existing car park on
the avenue country park for our parking
there's also car parking that a lot is
parking on the on the main road uh
hornbeam drive into the site
we don't want our parents parking on
silver birch way which is now the new
road that goes from hornbeam drive down
to the site
it's a residential road
there are parking bays there i
appreciate that anyone can park on those
bays but you know we're we're happy to
put signs up to say don't park on those
roads um on our website when we advise
um away teams
where to come we tend to park in the car
park along the road not to park on
silver birch way
there was a resident who previously who
parked his van outside his house no i
know that's not given a right to park
your your vehicle outside your house but
we put a sign up to say please don't
park here if you're from the football
club and it worked
we had a fun day on site last year
um i've got an aerial picture from a
drone that shows we asked people not to
park on silver birch way and no one
parked until the virg way so
we would work very much with
um our parents our spectators to ensure
they park in the right place which is in
the car park that's the most safe place
in our eyes or on the the main road of
hornbeam drive which i believe is
adequate for parking
are there any further questions
councillor willoughby
hi
um could i ask if if hopefully it won't
if there should be a problem with
parking would you be able to and put
marshalls out there to direct absolutely
i think as an added yeah um you know
we don't want to fall out of our
neighbors you know um
you know we were there first but that's
not that you know it's not how we want
to be
we just want to advise people to park in
a safe and secure way away from from
those houses let those people park
outside the house if they want to
it's probably about 150 yard walk from
the car park to the to the gates
um and so we want people to park in a
safe and appropriate manner basically
thank you
[Music]
yeah i'm still on about the car park
looking at the plan have you looked at
other ways of actually
um
spacing them out to give you more
space could be going in different
direction a different plumber in the car
park you can understand what it means so
i mean the car park on site or the yeah
the car comes out the car park on site
because of the the
the the consultation with sport england
sporting them don't want us taking away
playing space like i understand that so
we try to understand what how many
spaces we need
and it's governed on
primarily disabled parking parking for
coaches and match officials only so
that's what the sign will say on the
gate no one else will park on that on in
no spaces
um
the architect has provided those plans
they think that's the best way of
parking those cars 12 cars which is the
maximum it will be
without taking away playing space
thank you
are there any further questions yes
i'm a teacher then counselor
uh you haven't mentioned uh uh coaches
uh have you got sufficient room sorry
when i would say coaches i mean football
coaches i don't mean
i'm sorry
i mean manages you know for yeah
sorry
thank you chair uh just one more
question uh one of the conditions uh
which has been put forward by officers
uh is the opening hours uh which is
monday to friday um
so look at 1700 hours to uh to eight
o'clock at night and uh nine o'clock uh
until 10 o'clock in the evening on on
saturday sunday bank holidays are you
happy with those and you're happy to
stick to those
i believe that they're fair and then in
terms of you know we are close to our
neighbors we can't get away from that
these health and wealth are very very
close to where our grounds was so from a
noise point of view and social behavior
point of view they appear to be um more
adequate for us so you're happy to
steve
thank you for that thank you chair
any further questions
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
that's great
are there any questions for our officers
no aren't you lucky emily
okay thank you very much
this is our opportunity now to open the
floor for debate if there is one um
so it's the final part of the process
this discussion before i go any further
i would just like the clock to remind us
about
motions thank you chair
please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving the motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false or in other words
it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
chair may i just raise one point just
before members go into debates please
certainly it just relates to um a
condition that counselor fosters made
reference to chair but also conditions
10 and 11 on page
20. do you also note that condition 11
is
currently set out that the clubhouse
shall be used by members and family of
the club only in visiting football teams
and spectators only
there's also condition 10 share which
has been set out by officers regarding
private functions and members may or may
not want that to attach to any
to
slightly reword that condition to avoid
any doubt
allowing only private functions within
two years from the date of completion
and that will allow then officers and
the council to review that after two
year period in case
any issues are arising from any other
functions that take place in the
clubhouse i just wanted to be clear in
terms of the wording and just finely
chair normally the recommendation is
subject to the delegation of any minor
word changes being delegated to myself i
just ask if members are minded to grant
permission that those powers are
delegated to myself and should they
arise when we're drafting the decision
notice as appropriate
thank you chair
thank you
yes jay
just to
conclude in terms of the timings of the
motions
these should be moved and seconded
after the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
and that the chair will indicate when
this point has been reached and will
then invite motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerks if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair
thank you
just as to remind us that clerk has told
us to please remain a free frame from
moving any motions until we have
concluded our discussion and i'll open
the floor for debate
council armitage
yes thank you chair i've er looking at
this plan i think it's a
a very
brave one i don't know how much it's
going to cost but
these things usually get paid for one
way or another and
it's it's very good uh it's a really
good layout
and
in my former years i remember getting
changed in uh
these sort of well not these buildings
not the proposed one but the uh
storage ones and it's uh it's a bit
bleak in winter i'll tell you that now
and i think it's a great plan
and i'll support it
thank you anyone else counselor
yeah i just echo what council armitage
has said
i look at eight four and say that these
developments should be permitted where
they protect or enhance existing open
space sport and recreation facilities
and i think this goes far ahead of that
i think it's well thought out well
planned there'll be a really big asset
to that community
and i should be supporting him
any other
no okay i'm going councillor willoughby
um yeah i i support this as well i think
it's brilliant for the children
and it's been there a long time and yeah
i agree with what the other two councils
have said it's brilliant stuff
counselor hall
yeah i'd like to propose that we move
officers we're not there yet
okay
no other questions
no other comments okay well i'm going to
beat you to it roger i'm going to
propose this i think it's a fabulous
song
thank you
all those in favor
that's unanimous thank you mr stops
there you go
and good luck
sally said just to be clear that was to
approve officer recommendations again
taking on board the points made by the
planning development manager thank you
chair
that was to include the information
adrian gave us as well
[Music]
okay we'll move on to the second
application item four which is ned
forward slash twenty one forward slash
zero one four four three four slash fl
for drum field
this application is for the change of
use from office to a whole food takeaway
with new extractor flu and associated
alterations at one chesterfield road
drum field
again in line with our normal practice
i'm going to ask the planning manager
and officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans on the site
i will allow the offices to complete the
presentation consequently asking members
to please reserve any points of order or
questions till the end thank you
okay thank you chair um firstly i'll
draw members attention to the late
comments report set out to members
yesterday
and as as you say the application seeks
planning permission to change the use
of the existing premises from an office
juice class e-use to a hot
food takeaway falling within a sewage
generous use class
the sites located within the defined
settlement development limits for
trumpfield the drumfield conservation
area
in addition the application premise is
situated within a designated local
center for drone field
the applicant proposes
limited alterations to the building in
question comprising amended door
openings in addition to small plant the
rear of the premises
and a chimney to extract smells and
odours
the issues members will need to assess
and base your decision on are as follows
a the principle of the proposed
development and whether a hot food
takeaway is acceptable in the location
proposed when assessed against the
relevant policies of the local
development sorry of the development
plan
b the impact of the development on the
character and appearance of the area
with specific regard to the drumfield
conservation area and character
buildings referenced in the dronfield
neighborhood plan
c
the impact of the proposed use on the
immunity of neighbours
and finally d highway safety impacts
in terms of the
presentation slideshow the um
location plan shown shows the
application premises are edged in yellow
on the north situated on the
northeastern side of chesterfield road
as mentioned within the defined
settlement development limits for drum
field a crownfield conservation area and
a designated local center next slide
please
and the elevational drawings shown are
of the principal elevation of the
premises
and they illustrate the limited
alterations that are proposed which
include
the replacement and
renovation of
replacement of doors and windows and
renovation of
existing timber
in addition on the um
rear slope roof slope of the premises
is a flu which would be finished in a
matte dark gray paint
and in addition there are some
modest extraction uh units at the rear
which you can also see um there
next slide please
and these are some photos of the
premises which is formally used as a
st john's ambulance office
um this is the principal elevation and
the photo shows a number of other
existing commercial uses in the locality
um
neighboring the the application premises
and finally onto the
rear elevation
this shows the rear elevation of the
premises um in the
left
of the image you'll see a
first floor residential unit which is
the the closest um
residential use to the to the
application premises and that concludes
the
slides thank you
thank you
again in line with normal practice i'll
ask
any further questions for later and we
have two speakers i believe um
to speak on this application and the
first speaker is
councillor martin hannah ray
who's going to be an objector
if you could just say your name and then
you have three minutes good afternoon my
name is martin henron i'm an award
counselor for drumfield north on
gunfield town council i'm speaking on
behalf of the council and the response
to this application
um uh john field town council would like
to object to the application
the change of use from an office classy
to hot food takeaway with the um
extractor flues and associated
alterations
the the
building isn't as
the officer mentioned is in the
conservation area and it affects the
setting of a listed building um it's
contrary to several policies within the
drumfield neighborhood plan
um policy e2 is a
regards shop frontages in the town
center and um
development proposals at all to replace
or introduce shop fronts must be of high
quality contributing to an overall
improvement in terms of urban design and
architecture
in cutting out the front elevation to
form a new entrance it's substantially
going to alter the look of the existing
building and it would
these
and
class a5 will be supported where it can
be demonstrated it makes a positive
contribution to the viability and
vitality of the town center
there's no evidence within the
application that hot food takeaway would
make a positive contribution to the
viability or vitality of the 10th
century in fact it could negatively
impact the town with potentially
increased litter and parking issues
um and then policy d3 about good design
states that um supportive development
process proposals must respond
positively to the character and the
historic context of existing
developments within the town
the proposed illuminated signbox roller
shutters etc would not be in keeping
with the historic context of the
building or
the local conservation area
um the building is listed within the
drumfield neighborhood plan as a drum
field character building
and the structure of local heritage
interest and this it doesn't show on the
the drawings of course but there's a
keystone date over the arch 1873 and the
initials hs which refer to henry silcod
who was a local sickle maker
um
to develop falls within the conservation
and should be sympathetic to the
character and the appearance of
traditional styles in their designer
materials therefore we object to this
the
environmental health officer uh pointed
out that uh
30 seconds left sorry policy ah3r um
contravenes the neddc local plan the
conservation officer actually put in a
very detailed explanation and i hope
you've had a chance to read that and it
says the number of laws and policies
that this proposed development
contravenes dronefield civic society
also put in a very detailed uh
description which i hope you'll read
or you have had a chance to read
county highways did not object to this
that's three minutes
i can't believe it's the wrong building
location for this thank you if you'd
like to remain where you're seated so
there's any questions thank you
councillor foster
thank you chad yeah my question is what
were you about to say on the the dtc
issue with the highways sorry councillor
foster you're not allowed to do that
i wonder that then council hangman thank
you chair
are there any further questions
councillor hall
yeah uh
regarding parking uh could you tell me
if there is any parking available within
the area we saw a photo through the arch
and it looked like there was a few
parking bays there um i don't know
whether they relate to this building or
whether it's um
whether there is
zero parking in the area at all
apparently there is no parking provided
with the purchase of this building for
this purpose so there's no parking for
staff and there's no parking um off-road
for any um customers but by its very
nature um
takeaways people pull up usually in
vehicles park for a short space of time
or variable amounts of time and then
drive away and it will cause an increase
in traffic um the
you can see from the um aerial photo
that the there is a severe crossing
directly outside and the associated
zigzag lines so nobody should be parking
for quite some considerable distance
either side of this proposed takeaway
and then those double yellow lines on
both sides of the road stretching
towards strongfield station to the south
and then north um heading towards snape
hill lane there are some parking bays um
towards snape hill lane but
one of the other problems that really
makes this
a a a very very unsuitable location this
type of business is the fact that uh lee
road comes at a uh almost parallel uh to
chesterfield road sheffield road
this is number one um chesterfield road
so sheffield road chesterfield road um
chain you know the road changed its name
at that point um
and it's a really hazardous junction
it's a hairpin bend
and the visibility is very poor um so
from that point of view and and the fact
that there's local schools henry
fanshawe school is very close by
um and that zebra crossing needs to be
kept clear so the drivers have
visibility of any pedestrians stepping
onto the uh the crossing now
i can't see why
county highways didn't mention anything
i can only assume that maybe due to
covert they were working from home and
had a look at google earth certainly not
google's street view because it really
is a textbook example of
the wrong location for this type of
business we're off the factor of parking
we're off from the original question
here so we've i think we've all got the
gist that parking is an issue thank you
seriously any just remain where you are
just in case there are any further
questions
nope fine if you'd like to take your
seat thank you for your time no problem
our second speaker this
afternoon is susan burkett
representing the town council for
drawnfield north and the residents
you'd like
and then you've got three minutes uh
right yes my name's susan burkett uh and
i'm a drumfield town councillor
representing the drumfield north ward
um the same as mr councillor hamron um
i'm here today on behalf of the
residents who wish to oppose to this
planning application
uh having spent a number of hours with
them on friday afternoon talking to
various residents the most affected area
is a
is
holborn avenue which is actually behind
and above
the proposed application where the
building is
and for quite a number of years already
there's also another takeaway a couple
of doors down
which
over the years they've had to deal with
the smells the odours from the extractor
fan
at some point it actually set on fire
and the fire brigade couldn't quite get
to it properly
and they have a rat issue as well which
is getting worse
so their main concerns
are
if there's another takeaway it's going
to
add to the situation as it is now
um
pest control have been out to various of
these properties
and i think from the letters that you've
already received from the residents
there was one situation where pest
control did actually suggest that it
probably came from the chinese that's
already there
so if we have another takeaway which is
a couple of doors down
it's going to add
extra
um
possibilities of of rats and
and
things like that litter
obviously
other things like parking as council
hangran's just mentioned
but their main concerns
are that they can't use their back
gardens because it actually backs
onto where the buildings are and the
extractor fans are and the smells and
the odours are quite strong
and
some of the residents have got children
they can't play out in the garden as
much as they probably like to because of
the rats
and the smell
so um i just feel that
if there is
another takeaway
it's going to add even more pressure on
the residents that live on holborn
haven't
avenue
um and i just feel that um
as i say if it does go ahead
then
their daily way of life is going to be
affected 30 seconds left
and i just think that if we can consider
not putting another takeaway there it it
would be really helpful to the residents
of oldborn avenue and obviously we spoke
to residents on
uh the chesterfield stroke at sheffield
road as well and they got similar
concerns
thank you
thank you if you'd like to remain seated
in case there's any questions
councillor cooper
thank you chair um
you mentioned very briefly their parking
is there a parking issue at the chinese
takeaway yes there is they
where
where the china is it's two doors down
from where the proposed application is
and of course this is every crossing
there but where the chinese is it's
actually on a slight bend but people
just pull up outside on double yellow
lines
and it's very difficult for the traffic
to get past because on the other side of
the road there's no footpath
that's where the station
is just a curb up to her up to a wall or
a fence so there's there's not much room
and quite a few of the people do just
park on double yellow lines and going to
the chinese
um
are these issues reported to the police
regularly because obviously to me that's
a that's a
that's an offense it is an offensive
it's not something that has counters
we have any powers over as such
i mean it's it's it's the actual
reporting of such
and
getting some fines for people who do
that i guess that's the that's the thing
and that's what i'm looking at here
um it's it's hearsay until it's proven
and until this fines so well it's not
hearsay because i've actually seen it
myself
um
as for reporting things like this to the
police i i don't know if the residents
have i haven't got that information
nobody's actually mentioned that to me
but it does happen uh i live in john
field i drive past there quite often and
cars are always parked outside
the chinese
unfortunately we have a
we have the information from derbyshire
highways as you've
heard about and seen and written and
read about
that's unfortunately what we have to
work on
i appreciate that but at the end of the
day
my objection is more towards the smell
and the odor and the rats
all right the parking situation is a
problem
but i think from a safety point of view
and for people that actually live around
there i think we should consider their
feelings
and
what they have to put up with
um as i say simply chinese have been
there for quite a lot of number of years
and to actually add to the situation and
put another takeaway there at the moment
we have got 10 food establishments on
the bottom of drumfield we don't need
another one
that would make 11.
and i i just don't think it would
benefit drumfield
and it it makes
as some of the other residents have said
people walk along eating the meals they
throw the litter on the floor there's
noise they
and and that's what concerns people
because people do actually live on the
main road and a couple of doors away
from simply chinese and the other
eating places that are further down in
drumfield
so
you know there are ten
food places there already okay thanks i
it's just i'm looking for ways to try
and support if i can yes but obviously i
need i need the concrete evidence okay
thank you
any other questions councilor powell
um against the burkitt uh for the
benefit of members who might not know
the site uh could you explain the
context of obviously it's a main road
that goes through effectively the drone
valley
um and uh the you mentioned the flu
which obviously goes up to the roof
um could you explain where the houses
are in relation to that are they they're
directly behind the houses are they
behind and above yes
thank you yes
[Music]
any other questions counselor hall
yeah just uh thank you i'd just like to
ask where you talk about the um
footpath coming
to an end well not coming to an end but
one side of the road there's no footpath
so that's directly opposite the proposed
uh application i guess so the zebra
crossing is where
uh people would
cross to get to or from the railway
station i guess i'm trying to picture
because uh council henry has said
there's no parking whatsoever
it's not i'm trying to picture this it's
not just for customers i mean uh
fast food takeaways have a substantial
amount of deliveries for different
things whether it's
vegetables whether it's meat whether
it's drinks
plus the the um
waste disposal for the bins and things
like this i'm trying to picture it
because
uh
the chinese further down has got a
lock-up part for the bins to be put
where like if there's no footpath
opposite where are the bins going to be
i can't answer that for you because i've
actually been around the bike and it's
very small area and there aren't any
bins there at the moment
so i don't know where the bins would go
but as for deliveries
if they did uh have deliveries
the premises
the crossing is there and the premises
are there
so if they're making deliveries they're
going to be parking on the on the
crossing
because
there's no footpath on that side
and as lee road comes down you
immediately come to the zebra crossing
and then there's lucas gardens there
which is a grass verge
and
the residents
concerns are that they will actually
start to park on lunches gardens as well
and and block that part of the road off
but as for deliveries i i i cannot see
how they are going to safely
deliver
goods to those premises
without
causing an accident as i say the debra
crossing is there and the shops there
thank you
any other questions
no thank you if you'd like to take your
seat thank you
are there any questions for the officers
councillor elliot
thank you chad
my question to the officers is one of
the photos showed the rear of the
building where i assume the proposed flu
will be
and then we were led to believe to the
left of that is the is accommodation
there's a there's a door and some
accommodation if you bring up the photo
you'll be able to see it
uh is that flue going to go a meter past
any openable light or two meters past
any openable light
how does that one work is it like any
soil event stack where he has to go the
meter past
of course yeah sorry councillor yeah um
yeah the um
flu is is as as shown on the um
submitted details in terms of its
its physical construction
uh one thing
a white plastic door for some
residential property at the side of it
just like everybody would see that yeah
yeah that there's a there's a set of
stairs in the plastic door i assume the
the flu will be in the
in the left hand corner looking at it
it would be um
projected from the roof slope of the
application premises of course and um
would would go above
the adjacent
property as you can see
but just in terms of of that matter
module and really we've obviously saw
the views of our environmental health
officers who have advised that a
suitable condition
requiring a scheme for the extraction
dispersal and control of cooking odors
would
be a satisfactory way of addressing that
matter and they believe that it would be
an acceptable arrangement and not lead
to any
unacceptably harmful this amenity to the
occupiers of nearby property so we've
taken their views on on that matter and
consider that it could be controlled by
condition which for
information is conditioned to seven in
the offices report thank you what about
the noise from the fans because you're
going to be putting the fans up on the
on that rear elevation as well yeah
again that's that would be covered um as
i understand it within within that
condition so there would be
a requirement for them to demonstrate
that it's acceptable in
in a wider immunity sense not just from
the perspective of odours but also from
a
uh a noise nuisance perspective as well
so that would as i understand it that
would all be considered as as part of a
uh subsequently dealt with condition
yeah it's just that we're considering it
now and i'm considering the noise from
from the property now being the takeaway
the noise from the people in and out
the the noise from the fans the odours
from the chimney it all stacks up and
and i know that very well and that
there's always going to be delivery
drivers sat outside that premise waiting
to take orders to to and from that shop
where are they going to park because
that is on zigzags
and and yellow lines it it's actually
for me it's a disaster waiting to happen
has it been done as a desktop survey
from highways or being out there as
regards the highways comments it's not
alluded to in their comments as to
whether it's been done
with the benefit of a site visit or as a
desktop study but in effect what
highways offices are saying
is that there's an extent use of the
premises which is
um
traffic generating in theory um so so
that they they offset it against that
in addition the location they refer to
in their comments which is officers
we've interpreted to mean that drone
field is a sustainable location a level
one settlement in the local plan
and in that sense
there is
not a necessity for
parking in the locality to to
not result in any unacceptable harm from
a highway safety perspective because it
is
by definition it's a local centre it's
one of the most sustainable
locations in our district um so so we've
interpreted in in that sense
and also highways of as opposed to being
a negative highways have said that the
on street parking restrictions are in
fact
a positive because they will
in effect preclude
parking in the immediate vicinity of the
site so that's the way that we've
interpreted the highways comments and as
you can see
dcc highways officers have raised no
objections to the proposals
sorry can i just run will you just run
that past me again you say there's
parking within the side parking there's
parking restrictions
on the adjacent high the the highway and
immediate vicinity of the site which
they've said is not
a negative in the sense that in effect
it precludes parking within the vicinity
of the site which can be accessed by
sustainable means
you see i i've listened to other people
talking about you know it's not it's not
for for us to worry about how it's
policed but the police don't police
parking anymore the county council and
the highways with their
little meter guys police the police that
and with the very nature of the of the
uh shop
no but no council is going to put people
out you know eight while 12 at night or
whatever time to actually police the
parking they'll be gone home at five
o'clock
so it'll never get seen or dealt with i
think ultimately we've taken the views
of highways officers we've assessed it
against the relevant
policies in the sense that the npps
states that development shouldn't lead
to any unacceptable highway harm or
cumulative severe harm and we've agreed
we've determined and concluded in this
instance that
this proposal wouldn't result in any
unacceptable harm
in highlights thanks very much for your
answers i i have to disagree with you on
that i really do
and and to have an eleventh takeaway on
the bottom of that road is just for me
it's just one too far but thanks very
much for your answers
i've got three speakers um councillor
armitage councillor foster and
councillor dayton i'll take them in that
order thank you
thank you chair uh could you point out
where the uh listed building is in
comparison to the what one the list yeah
the list the listed structure is the lee
road bridge as i understand it
the application building itself is uh
um highlighted in the neighborhood plan
as a
character building i think is referred
to
right so in your opinion uh it won't
cause harm having uh this building there
yeah well we've sought the views of our
um in-house conservation officer on the
mata and as you'll have seen
with the proposals there's a
an amended scheme being submitted which
comprises very limited
alterations to the shop front
which the
the
replacement doors and the um
renovation of the timbers at the front
of the building have been identified by
our conservation area the conservation
officer sorry as an enhancement existing
building
the flu is
um clearly not an enhancement
but in
in assessing the scheme as a as a whole
it's been determined that it would be a
preservation of the building because
there are enhancements
which would outweigh or at least um
uh match the the harm caused by that
that flu which would be finished in a
a dark gray matte finish which would be
um
relatively sympathetic
and just add to that chair as well the
the reference is made to the
neighborhood plan and you've heard
various comments on that this afternoon
but with respect to the specific
annotation within the neighborhood plan
there would be no impact on the keystone
that is referred to with the
letters and reference to the sickle
maker nor indeed to the
um the
um chimneys or the hearts in the the
rear car part which you made a reference
to as well which are referred to in the
neighborhood plan and and gravestones
within that as well so there'll be no
harm to the various sanitation set out
in the neighborhood plan
well if i could just pick you up on this
flu
i mean
there it is
and you said it will enhance the actual
development well i can't see how it will
as far as i'm concerned
you say that uh it's there and
where its position is uh won't cause any
smells going to the next door
building
but
i mean would you like to go and
sit next to it all day every
day you know i just cannot see how you
can expect
it won't go straight up depends which
way the wind is and the poor person
living next door will get blasted with
it
24 hours a day and i think it's
ridiculous to say
yeah sorry to interrupt as mentioned
before we've taken the advice of um
the environmental health officers of the
council and and that they believe that
it can be controlled by a way of
condition so we've no reason to conclude
otherwise
moving on councillor foster
uh yeah thank you chair uh just a couple
of points i'd like to
mention three points uh at this stage uh
if i take that order build a situation
uh first um
you mentioned a few times in your use of
words that it uh that they believe it
could be controlled but let's look at
the actual words at the bottom of page
38. so this is the environment health
officer
devised that whilst the proposed change
of use could give rise to significant
levels of order
it's about the choice of words here so
they've said that it could give rise to
significant levels of order significant
it's very important that yeah and they
could be cut
and
which could impact upon neighboring
amino tank now that's just not the the
flat next door but has been pointed out
by councillor powell earlier it's the
road it's holborn uh avenue behind
and that's why if you've been there
yourself now i don't know if you've done
a desktop the same as uh highways but if
you've been out and seen that road
yourself
that that chimney where it would be much
the same as simply chinese which is two
doors down
is directly behind the gardens and the
actual gardens of whole bone are above
that chimney and there's there's many
complaints and you can see a lot of them
have written in from holborn they can
already smell simply chinese
now
you've said they say that significant
levels of order and it could impact upon
nearing the immediate state and it could
be controlled that's not enough
that's what's in writing we're choosing
our words around here and officers are
choosing their words but that's not
enough for residents at all so that's
the first that's the first point i want
other other members to be aware that's
what it actually says on the paper
uh the next one
is dcc have said there's no extant use
of the premise uh there is extant use of
the premise there is no this is
currently empty along that whole stretch
it's the only property which is not
currently used now the photo you've
shown is an old photo next door we've
got a new recruitment
office and on the other side we've got
banner jones
the solicitors
so it's a very old photo that you so so
we've got so we're not worried about in
drone field about the these properties
uh being empty and not being councilman
foster question please no statement okay
thank you chair
uh so uh it's to make the point about
bcc that it's been declared that there's
an extent use and there is no uh there
is no extent use of the mate so the
point at the point of it being any
further use
would obviously impact on uh on
on the traffic there because it's not
currently being used and they're
assuming it is so dcc have got that
wrong it's been tabletop but they've got
that point wrong and when it comes to
parking restrictions i'll actually take
your comments on this those parking
restrictions about those days further on
they're not police yeah there's one
there's only the police don't police
then we know that some i'm on the road
safety committee and it's being raised
on our road safety committee in town the
other two issues the other two people
that would police them would either be
the district or dcc to once to uh
council council cooper's comment comment
they are not the private company that
comes around there do not it's not on
their route so they currently don't go
up and down there so there's so does no
there's nobody there to police that but
the police
statement counselor foster
and the question is comments on those
three because they've been brought those
three particular points have been
brought up during this discussion
comments from uh councillor elliot so
and the answers have been incorrect so
it's uh some clarity on those three
points yeah
in terms of the extent use i would say
that they're
just by virtue of the premises being
vacant doesn't mean that the use has
been abandoned
so there isn't as officers we believe
that to be an office use and that's what
the change of use application is from
so so i would disagree with
there being no anneal use i would say
that there is a use but it happens to be
vacant
um so in theory that you use could be
resumed and it could be resumed with a
traffic generating office use um
so i think i think that would be our
view on that that particular point
um as regard the odors i have visited
the site and all i would reiterate on
that is that we've taken the advice of
our environmental health officers as
regards that
and
refer to the potential for some um
significant impact in terms of
odors but they do indeed conclude that
such a condition as they've recommended
would be would be sufficient to
control that matter
and
final
engine and taking a view as officers in
light of that guidance that the
proposals wouldn't lead to any
unacceptable harm in highway safety
terms contrary
to the
policies
you can come back on just one of those
points i'll come back once yeah on the
second point about orders
concluding it would be sufficient they
haven't they haven't that's the point
you tried to make they said it could be
controlled and they have to say it would
be controlled they said it could be
controlled and could be controlled it's
entirely different what you just said
would be sufficient they haven't said
that it's not there's nothing right mr
wilson they haven't said it
thank you chair councillor dayton
yeah on the
safety issues the traffic has the dcc
taking into a consideration that that is
the main road through drone field to
what is uh
um
there are huge
companies like banners and uh
palmers and there are huge lorries
coming down that road regularly all day
every day and that if people are parking
whether they're supposed to or not on
that road
as i found out nearly to my cost the
other day the lorries don't stop they
keep coming even if it's not there right
away they nearly had me and my husband
off the road so i would suggest that dcc
go back and take another look at whether
they think that road is suitable for
putting yet another takeaway on it and
increasing the number of parking places
and traffic coming down that road
on this
i based the claim that it's just not
suitable
those chairs and the fact that there is
parking restrictions outside the
premises and i know
stream if that's incorrect but what we
are not able to do as a council is take
into account potentially unlawful or
unregulated parking we have to operate
give advice on the basis of the
information we have and the proper use
of the highway and in this instance has
comment outline chair the higher
authority conclude that view of the
extant use that the premises has as a
classy use and that would allow for its
uses for a variety of uses and without
granted planning permission and the on
street parking restrictions already
right that there wouldn't be any severe
danger caused to highway safety by the
proposed use chain that's the basis our
advice to members and members will need
to take a view
on that in their deliberations on the
application
thank you are there any further
questions counselor will be
um can you tell me what the hours of
opening um have been asked for for this
um
building please
yeah it's been requested that the house
of opening would be
um from midday until half past 11 on any
day
thank you
any further thank you officers
having heard everything today and the
office recommendations i'm going to open
the floor for debate councillor foster
then council armature yeah uh thank you
chad i'll make a start with the traffic
side of things we've heard from uh
councils that have come to speak on
behalf of drumfield council and the ward
uh if you look at uh the issues that
have been here in the past and to answer
council cooper's comments uh from
earlier they have been complained about
the parking there and it's been
complained to the town council through
the road safety committee and it's being
raised with a local pcso and i'm on the
road safety committee along with uh
councillor dayton here so so we have uh
we have raised that issue and they say
like much much as most people would
guess there's not a lot they can they
can do about it it's parking on double
yellows uh they park on double yellows
uh on the vendors of the road
as we've heard outside simply to chinese
which is just adjacent to this
to this proposed uh change of use uh hot
food takeaway the hot food takeaway
actually sits bang in the middle of the
zigzags
that's where it actually actually sits
and that's where people will end up
parking now i know we've heard from
officers that we can't take that into
account but it's actually what will
happen in practice we've only got to
think about the this same planning
department gave permission to fat sams
only a few years ago which is just down
the road and it's on a roundabout double
yellows and everyone always parks on the
actual edge of the roundabout on the
double yellows is what happens in
practice and we do have to give some
consideration to that when we're
thinking of residents and we're thinking
of road safety this is what will
actually happen if it gets planned if it
gets given planning
planning permission it will be exactly
the same as that and we've heard that i
won't go over the rest of the parking
but road safety is a major issue there
now i don't believe uh dcc have looked
at this properly they have not looked at
it properly and there is a transit
council so that other question there is
a policy there policy id3 um where we
could uh look at uh he said if there
would be an acceptable impact on highway
safety we can judge ourselves we don't
have to uh take into account one console
t uh the highways the highways would not
object if you put it in the middle of
the road or in the middle of a
roundabout they just would not i know
that's a bit facetious saying that but
we know they don't here and we know the
difficulties
we've had with them uh on to the smells
itself
i've covered that with the smells uh i
think probably probably at length the
fact that it's a conservation area there
is uh there are ten um takeaways there
they are little italia tahini is simply
chinese village fisheries timber guard
and dronefield delhi spice garden
this
you have to be very careful right okay
uh there are the ten there's ten of them
uh and out of all of them uh eight of
those are in the conservation area for
me and we can this is the part of the
debate
that's enough tens enough so if that's
that part uh there
um when it comes to uh about improving
the immunity and improving drum fill
bottom
we've got no empty shops down there
there's no empty shops they've all been
filled that's not an issue either
um
that's that point
uh
i'll give way to somebody else now we'll
come back on further points as we come
along i'll take another turn thank you
chair
i've got councillor armitage then
council elliott
uh thank you chair
well
uh as far as i'm concerned this uh
application just breaks all the rules uh
as regarding uh we've got the
drum fill neighborhood plan
uh
you've got policy e2
uh that's frontage
in town center
e4 opt food takeaways and d3
uh good design now it's in the
conservation area so here we are we're
gonna have this flu
now
if that flu was 30 feet high
the people next door would still get the
older i don't care what the officer says
uh you know prevailing winds
humidity and one thing in another the
people next door will quite frankly be
gassed out
if you look at uh
the uh
ss-1 sustainable development well it's
not there are already 10 of these uh in
drawn field they don't need any more
you know there's
s sdc5
development with the cons within a
conservation area well it is
and uh
there's the development effect in a
listed building well it will to a
certain extent
and you know this thing about the uh
uh
parking well it's
it's it's ludicrous quite frankly
uh
everybody knows outside every uh
takeaway it doesn't matter what sort of
lines or what have you
they all part there deliberate all the
rest of them they park on
half on the footpath and half on the on
the road and this will happen just the
same
and it's right next to it and
yes thank you
it's right next to a uh
to a zebra crossing and you won't be
able to see
you know and it's it's an accident
waiting to happen and
i can't support this uh this application
whatsoever i'm sorry but that's it and i
don't know why officers have gone for it
but there you go
councillor elliot
thanks chad
chair
i think it you know we we did pull
councillor foster upon the on the debate
part of it but
and there will be quite a few people
around this table who don't know that
area and i think for for those people it
was very useful for him to actually put
forward
in in the way he did the the situation
there i've spoke at length throughout
this application about
about the parking about the odors and
and the rest of it the parking for me uh
on those zigzags on a crossing with the
school opposite for me from from word go
it's a no-no and i don't know whether
that's a statement or whether you want
to debate that as well
but uh yeah i i i'm like councillor
amateurs i just can't support it i can't
see where it's going to be safe or right
um before i let councillor foster back
in is there anyone else wants anything
i've got councillor hall councillor
willoughby councillor jones and i'll
come back to you councillor foster
that's okay now just say one thing at
some point chair please but i'll happy
to
come in when appropriate yep okay thank
you
[Music]
we'll start with councillor hall
thank you one of the things i'd like to
emphasize is we've heard from
uh
counselor berkey
yeah
sorry i had a brain please then about
the um footpath on one side i mean i've
lived in dronefield all my life so i do
know a fair bit about the area and about
the previous use yes it was used by
saint john's ambulance but it was only a
part-time office
i think they used it for brand band
practice it may have been used one
evening say from 7 30 till
10 30 in the evening it wasn't 12 until
11 12th
midday till half 11 at night the other
thing as well that they've not picked up
on tcc i mean the office has been shot
for a couple years or whatever the thing
they've not picked up on is there's a
wooden ramp that's been shot a couple of
years and this
could affect disabled or people like
that because now to get from one side of
the railway station to the other for
anyone that uses a wheelchair that
pushes a pram or
use it can't walk over the steps that
yes there is a footbridge from one
platform to the other
but you have to cross it by steps the
only way you can get round is to cross
the road in front of the
railway station because there is no
footpath the other side you then have to
walk down the footpath use this zebra
crossing that is in front of this
proposed shop and then go up the ramp
and then down up that when i say ramp
not the wooden ramp that's shut the
footpath
uh only road and then go down the ramp
the other side the tarmac ramp to the
other platform and it's for anyone
whether they're going to the railway
station or coming back
from it it is such an important crossing
and any vehicles that were to park there
would uh the the are the footpath is
very narrow one side of the road there's
no footpath the other side of the road
is very narrow so it for anyone even if
they were to say well they could park
the car the van half on the footpath
half off it that's not
suitable either because
it wouldn't
block the full path or whatever i raised
that either but thank you i just wanted
to pull that point across
i'm going to allow um councillor jones
council willowby and then i'm going to
ask councillor foster to round it up
councillor jones
thank you
um
we have very similar problems in the
area i represent
and it's about parking restrictions
outside takeaways i don't know
trumpfield very well so i can't you
haven't physically seen that situation
but i know that we have a situation very
similar
where there's parking restrictions that
you're totally ignored even though
there's a car park only a few meters
away
and we've had a fatality already on that
short piece of road
and i think we have to learn from
mistakes and make sure that we're aware
that people are ignoring them of the
regulations
every day when i drive down there this
car's parked on the lines
and there is no policing and we've taken
it up with the police many times
but nothing happens
thank you council will be
[Music]
i can't support this
um either i'm actually supported someone
in the past
that's actually lived this life
and the odor wasn't controlled from this
particular business
their windows needed to be kept closed
at all time and the noise level
from the staff that
obviously need to go in earlier than 12
o'clock
to prepare
if they're closing at half past 11
there's there's all the cleaning down to
do
there's a lot of disruption there for
any residents uh that are close by
i can't support this either sorry
councillor foster if you'd like to round
us up uh yeah i'll mention one more
issue just quickly before a round up on
this uh one of the issues which has not
been mentioned by a dcc or by our
officers uh is that this is actually a
designated school room i know that as a
county councillor so the designated
school room did go up uh the wooden ramp
uh council halls mentioned earlier but
that one's been closed for a number of
years so the designated school route
passes narrow pavement
is past is past this actual takeaway and
across that crossing so that's the route
for fanshawe uh students uh opening
hours are from 12 noon uh so when it's
open at noon they're going to be going
there for uh so
there's going to be lots of concerns
around that if this is opened as a
takeaway and i don't think that that's
not even being discussed by any of us
yet but it is it is actually a school
rule uh there's also a question there on
how it relates to our own policies on
trying to reduce child obesity a
district something we've all talked
about quite a lot in various committees
so that's one thing just one extra point
i wanted to mention
uh summing up on this uh yeah i i am got
a lot to say other than a motion which
you intend on putting
uh as soon as you open the next stage of
the uh the
next stage of the meeting up on this uh
and i've got quite a few uh details here
which i'd like to uh
go through with you and take my time to
go through on the different of the rep
and the various different policies
so thank you chair
thank you
okay i'm sorry
yes counselor i'm sorry adrian
yeah just just the one point to share
that in response to a comment that uh
councilor armitage made in respect of
the officers recommending approval just
and would like to make a couple of
points on that please
colin's gone through in in some detail
setting out um the officer's view on the
various issues that members of of ray's
chair and i i note some members comments
on that and the planning committee will
need to come to a view based on all
material matters this afternoon on the
application that that is that the role
of the committee obviously in terms of
the the officer advice chair that's
that's our role and we've sought to do
that setting out the various development
plan policies
and our response to them and of course
the technical matters in respect to
environmental health and highways in
particular and it's on the basis of all
those elements shared that officers have
concluded as we have done and
recommended approval so we we've sought
to
take on board all the comments that are
made and assess them against your
policies and come to our view and i just
thought it was worth making that point
yeah in response to what councilor
armitage said but obviously respect very
much shared the role of the committee
this afternoon in yourselves weighing
those issues up and coming to a
conclusion on the application all that
asks chair as if um
if in making recommendations to
committee and taking votes if as
officers we can be clear in respect of
the the various reasons and that members
may be putting forward particularly if
members are minded to refuse the
application so we can be clear
in putting those forward should the
application be refused chair thank you
thank you i am going to open the floor
now for motions and
council foster
thank you chair yeah i'd like to propose
that we refuse planning permission uh
for these reasons uh starting with uh
policy ss7
which is uh is referred to on page 36
and that's uh the unallocated land uh
policy it says uh halfway down there in
that larger paragraph um
the the these uh developments will be
permitted where that the proposed
development is a
is appropriate in scale design and
location and character and function of
the settlement so that's particular part
a so bear with me as i work through
these uh i don't believe it is
so it's my view and that is a material
consideration that it's not
um
appropriate so that's the first part
uh
second part e2 i'm looking for that i'll
come back to e2
e4
with e4 under 7.2 on page 36 in
particular a c and d
so a that can be demonstrated to any ddc
in consultation with timecastle it makes
a positive contribution to the
viability and vitality of the town
center it doesn't
that's again that's my view and from
what i've heard from a lot of people
that have spoken today i don't believe
it's theirs either so that's a
c would not result in more than two a5
units being located adjacent to each
other we've got simply chinese uh adora
so down
so for me that fits in with that with
what our neighborhood plan was
originally written for uh it might not
be bang next door but um
one point that hasn't been mentioned
that new recruitment uh place next door
i suspect it still might have this the
same uh
planning permission because it used to
be a cafe
it was a cafe and it closed down that
was cafeteria so there's every chance it
could be next door so certainly c
and then d would not negatively impact
on the immunity of surrounding
businesses and business well we talked
about that at length about residents
with smell about the uh the smaller uh
properties just down from this
uh i think it's called the prior eh they
uh where it's an older person's um
uh
it's what the smaller flats for all the
residents
and that's only and that's only a couple
of doors down you've got the immunity of
the resident which is above it in that
fat in that flat and then above you've
got a holborn avenue so i'm speaking
about all those residents there so it
would negatively impact upon the
immunity of those residents so that's a
c and d
um
that part was e4 d3
[Music]
let's have a look now i'm going to i'm
i've got uh i'm looking for a bear with
me just take your time thank you
um
there's deep we've got d3
sdc5 on page 37
and d2
so
sdc5
uh where they preserve or enhance the
character or appearance of of the area
and it's set in well this certainly
won't do that and that's our view again
uh that's my view again on that so
that's sdc5
uh d2
let's have a look at this one uh this is
part of the dromfield neighborhood plan
and this is about the character and the
structure of local heavy heritage
interest officers consider the proposed
change of views would establish a viable
new use of the historic building
securities maintenance and longevity uh
this can be secured by other means um it
can easily be taken on as a as
something other than a fast food
takeaway so i don't believe that's that
that's true at all so d2
um
let's have a look
and
also id3 of the local plan on page
39
which is uh as we've spoken earlier
that's about uh traffic
and uh it should only be prevented or
refused on highway grounds if there
would be an exceptional impact on
highway safety well i do believe there
would there would be an unacceptable
impact on highway safety now this this
part could well be challenged at appeal
because we've got highways again not
objecting
uh to this or not providing any concern
from dcc but i'd still like to include
it in
the grounds for refusal because it's
what we've concentrated a lot on and
it's what residents feel too so maybe
not uh we can't put um
uh let's have a look the bit we will
include the part if there will be an
unacceptable impact on highway safety
and it's that part uh we can put in it's
our job to say whether there would be an
acceptable incap and i
sincerely believe there will be i really
do
um and i think that covers all of them
so id3 d2 sdc5 d3 e4 e2 and ss7 do you
want to go back to e2
i'm looking for it but as i'm speaking
it's difficult
right right thank you thank you that's
why i didn't have it's uh e2 shop
frontages in the town center so it's
much as exactly said in the drumfield
town council uh response that's being
put forward
so thank you councillor appreciate that
so um our office is happy with all those
so just to be clear then chair then that
the um
the motion is to
refuse planning planning permission
against officer recommendations on the
grounds that they're contrary to
our approval would be contrary to
policies ss7 e2 e4
d3
sdc5
d2 and id3 all of those yeah and uh e4
if we split it down to ac and d please
and just
the specific references
apologies you care can i just uh come in
for a second please you certainly might
i'm just in in response to councillor
foster's comments check just
seem to me bearing in mind what
um caster foster said is that there are
four elements that
members will be taking their
votes on
and that is in respect to the principle
of development
and particularly in relation to policy
ss7 that councillor fosters mentioned
there are issues regarding heritage so
conservation area and the comments of
the drumfield neighborhood plan in
respect of policy sd5
and
i think
policy d3 is relating to that
and then
an e2 and that's the impact on the shot
frontage this obviously the issues
around highway safety and council
fosters made reference to policy id3 and
then there's the issue on amenity which
i think council foster particularly made
reference to policy
e4 of the local plan but there i believe
there may be other
relevant policies in the in your own
local plan in respect of that chair so i
it would be my
recommendation to members that if you
are minded to refuse the application
that it is split up into those four
areas with the supportive policies as
outlined by councillor foster
and it's set out in those terms in in
four elements chair but if members are
minded to refuse the application on that
basis it would be my suggestion that
that
refusal is issued following consultation
with yourself and the vice chair of the
committee to ensure that we
encapsulate the
um members of planning committee's
wishes particularly
i hope that helps share that but that
would be my recommendation to to members
anyway
i'm happy with that recommendation but
if i can also be included uh in that as
well as the chair and vice chair please
if that's the accessible chair exactly
so as it stands then
jim we can't hear you
can you hear me now yes thank you yeah i
think my only concern would be
so that's where there are more than two
um a5 units adjacent to each other
um it may well be the case that that is
the case there are there will be more
than two a5 units
uh however
this is the only
um
[Music]
um grounds of objection that
is
um
cannot be challenged if that if
if there aren't more than 25 units it's
a fairly black and white position so i
would suggest that
um adrian um or planning checks the
position as to
what what units are adjacent to the
current um or the the application site
and if if there isn't
two a5 units adjacent to each other that
that be excluded from the um
from the grounds of rejection
uh if if there aren't more than 25 units
adjacent then that's that's fair enough
that can't be up
uh but i if there isn't then we couldn't
really uh justify that as a grounds
period
thank you
okay
i think the motion's on the table it's
been seconded but i've been advised we
best go through roll call for this vote
yeah i think so i was going to take that
yes i'll read your name please tell me
if you're fought against or wish to
abstain counsellor armitage
yes
yes for clarity it is to turn it down
councillor cooper
councillor dayton
councillor elliott
council mark foster
four council
roger hall
four
council hearts horn four
councillor jones
council powell
four
council rouse
cancer rough
four council winley
four
chair that's eleven four and one
abstention
if the motion's been carried thank you
very much
if you'd like to leave you can thank you
moving on to the next item planning
appeals and i call on the planning
manager to explain our next report
appeals lodged and determined thank you
[Music]
okay
the details are for members in their
papers you'll see that there were three
appeals dismissed in the the previous
period and they do make interesting
reading and i review members will have
read the decision notices already so i
went to too many details but in terms of
the appeal at market street at clay
cross that was an interesting decision
based primarily on the
mass impact on the conservation area so
read very interestingly in terms of the
monopoles impact on the entrance the
conservation area and how it would
adversely impact on that particular
element and that the advice we received
from the the council's conservation
officer chair was instrumental in that
decision which
expresses the benefit of having that
position in post in the council in terms
of the application by mr derek mapp and
the appeal again chair very interesting
decision
based on various elements but it was
developed in the green belt of a
previously developed site but the
inspectors discussion of impact on
openness again makes
good reading and hopefully will
be assisting members in
your decisions on similar applications
in the greenbelt particularly of
previously developed sites
and finally chair the one at killer
marsh
related to two dwellings where we have
now approved single dwelling but again
these inspectors support for the attack
taken by the council in terms of the
over development of the site with the
two units was well received by ourselves
as officers and i'm sure by members as
well but if there are any questions on
any of the elements set out in the
appeals pay per chair happily take them
now
are there any questions counselor foster
yeah just a comment i'd just like to say
i
came by officers absolutely excellent
work having these uh with these results
you know uh would be the right thing for
the for the residents of northeast
docker but we're also keeping costs down
as well that's what we're doing with
these appeals so i'd like to say good
work thank you chad
thank you
everybody else happy with that thank you
very much adrian and your officers for
this afternoon
and thank you committee
enjoy the rest of your afternoon
you